so given that context what are your
feelings as a human being uh and what is
your analysis as the former senior
advisor to the president under the Trump
administration of the current situation
in Israel and Gaza so I think you did an
excellent job of summarizing a lot of
the the context but watching what's
unfolded over the last 48 hours has been
truly heartbreaking to see we're still
in the early stages of what's developing
but seeing the images uh on X of um you
know militants uh terrorists going door
too with machine guns gunting down
innocent civilians uh seeing beheaded
Israeli soldiers seeing uh young
20-year-olds at a rave uh a dance party
to celebrate peace uh with militants
flying in and then you know shooting
machine guns to to kill people
indiscriminately uh seeing uh young
children uh captive and then held
prisoner seeing 80-year-old grandmothers
a holocaust Survivor also being taken
captive uh these are just
images and actions that we have not seen
in this world since uh 911 this is a
terror
attack on the scale of which uh we have
not seen and it's been incredibly hard
for a lot of people to
comprehend um my heart goes out
obviously to uh all of the the families
of the victims uh to the families of
those who are held uh in captive now and
uh to all of Israel because one of the
beautiful things about the state of
Israel is that when one Israeli is
hurting the entire nation comes together
uh it's a shame that it's taking an
action like this to unify the nation but
I have seen uh incredibly uh beautiful
signs over the last 48 hours of a
country coming together uh the Jewish
people have have been under oppression
before uh the Jewish people know what
it's like and seeing people rally
together to uh fight for their Homeland
to to to try to reestablish safety uh is
is um is a very beautiful thing to watch
I wish it wasn't something we had to
watch but it is uh with that being said
though the backdrop I've been speaking
to friends over the last couple days
I've one friend I spoke with um last
night who was saying that uh you know a
good friend messaged him saying I'm
going in we're going to do some
operations to try to free some of the
hostages held in one of the kutes
messaged him the next morning he was one
of the first through the door to try to
free these hostages and he was killed by
a Hamas militant and sadly we're going
to be hearing many many more stories of
Brave Israeli soldiers trying to uh get
these terrorists out of Israel trying to
free innocent civilians who
unfortunately are risking their lives uh
to do it and um you you know they're all
heroes but some will have less good fith
than others uh sadly so it's a very very
heartbreaking moment um and I do think
that it's very important at this moment
in time for the entire world to stand
behind Israel I think that Hamas has
shown uh the entire world who they
really are I think what their aim is
what they're willing to do um and you
know all of the uh strong security that
Israel's put in place
over the last years which in some
instances was criticized I think is now
being validated that um that there was a
real threat that they were looking to
deter so um short answer is my heart is
broken uh praying for peace praying for
strength praying for um praying for
Israel to do what it needs to do to
avoid being in this situation again
which is either eliminating or severely
degrading hamas's capabilities uh there
there cannot be peace in Israel and in
the Middle East while there is a terror
group um that is being funded by Iran
that is allowed to uh flourish and is
allowed to plan operations that are
going to aim to kill innocent civilians
and so as somebody who was formerly in
this position who uh was intimately
involved with Israel with uh the
strategies to to minimize uh attacks
from Hamas and to try to uh turn the
region around and I think we did do a
very substantial job on president Trump
the Middle East went from one of the
most chaotic regions in the world you
had uh Isis uh in 2016 Isis had a
califate the size of Ohio they were
beheading journalists they were um they
were they were killing Christians um
they controlled 8 million people they
were planning attacks um uh all over the
world from their their caliphate they
were uh using the internet to radicalize
people we had the San Bernardino
shooting in America we had the Pulse
Nightclub shooting uh in in in
Orlando and there was real threat and
then you had Iran uh which was given
$150 billion in a Glide path to a
nuclear weapon and they were using their
Newfound riches to fund Hamas Hezbollah
the houthis uh different Rebels uh all
over the the region that were looking to
destabilize further Syria was in a civil
war where 500,000 people were killed
Yemen was destabilized syri Libya was
destabilized and it was just a mess and
all of America's allies had felt
betrayed president Trump came into power
we rebuilt the the trust and the
relationships with all of our
traditional allies and we were able to
eliminate Isis the Cal territorial
caliphate and then we were able to
project strength in the region really go
after Iran's uh wallet uh we were able
to stop uh through through crushing
sanctions a lot of their financial uh
resources which they were using to fund
all these Terror groups and so we left
the Middle East uh with six piece deals
and and a fairly uh peaceful world so
seeing what's happening I think it was
completely avoidable I think it's
horrible to see that it's occurring uh
and I pray that those in power will make
the right decisions to uh to to to
restore safety but also to potentially
create uh a better Paradigm uh for peace
in the
future
I